ah oui c'est vrai qu'au bureau y aller
l'arrivée des courriers quoique assez
compliquée en est et vos débuts à une
fille donc qui dit la chef depuis celle
plus ancienne qui est là depuis 15 ans
s'appelle josette et puis on en rajoute
et 6,6 me semble ça fait 6 + snhf ça
fait 7 et quelques foyers du renfort en
année parce qu'avec le climat ça change
quand il fait plus chaud il ya un peu
plus de cela 10 et puis quand il fait un
peu plus frais ça se calme un petit peu
[Musique]
josette vous êtes responsable du
courrier du fan club de claude combien
de lettres par semaine une trentaine de
milles environ pour le moment et ça ne
fait que s'accroître et vous êtes
combien pour trier tout ça sommes sept
et en a marre on arrive à peu près à 100
1000 par mois qu'on demande un petit peu
de mal à y arriver mais le courrier de
l'eau toute la france et même de
l'étranger de france particulièrement
mais aussi d'étranges et même des états
unis et du canada un haussement toute
l'europe écrit toute l'europe oui
belgique suisse italie mais enfin même
haïti la guadeloupe en ce moment de
cette loi dit avait fait un petit séjour
et on reçoit des lettres illustrées très
coloré il ya combien de fans à peu près
dans toute l'europe dans toute l'europe
je pense c'est difficile de donner un
chiffre mais fourchette une fourchette 3
4 millions de fans 3,4 à taux plein
c'est réellement d'après les récents
sondages qu'on a fait c'est pas un
chiffre des grossistes a juré m
est ce que tu te rends compte que tous
les gens qui travaillent pour toi sont
des fans
ah oui ça surement maintenant parce que
la première question d'occuper est une
fan donc elles ne pourraient avoir des
conversations très précise que des
conversions de fans aiment prépa en
avoir d'autres donc je suppose qu'à la
carte blanche a choisi qu'ils veulent
fait venir qui qu'elle veut donc elle
organise son système mais je suppose
qu'elle prend des fans et j'en connais
certaines qui sont des femmes qui
travaillent au bureau et qui a pris
toute la nuit après avoir travaillé
sérieusement d'ailleurs parce qu'on a
ajouté je les vois pas enfin le font
semblant d'aller faire pipi trace en
temps pour vous rencontrer dans des
escaliers
mais en général sont sérieusement
cloître et là où elle travaille et puis
dans le reste de la soirée de la nuit
d'ailleurs comme toutes les autres fans
parisienne elles suivent
j'ai 15 ans cet avantage parce qu'elle
est nous vous trier le courrier vous
êtes une fan de claude et c'est parce
que vous êtes fan que vous travaillez au
courrier pour l'approcher tous les jours
quand ils y ont vu autrement le sort
on attend en bas du bureau et puis aussi
on va devoir devant chez lui quand la
main
chicago
le combat on va les tuer mon choix
pourquoi des courtils vous serre la main
ça vous fait quoi
ça nous fait le plaisir vous vivez en
fonction de lui ah oui vous n'avez que
lui
bah oui
les costes et possède beaucoup de
qualités ces cellules il est unique en
son genre alors y'a pas d'autres entrent
dans votre vie que claude non et ça vous
gêne pas et qu'ils aient des enfants qui
les désavantage avec d'autres fables
vous n'êtes pas exclusive
bah non c'est normal vous voulez pas
tout à vous mais la personne claude
[Musique]